great I just start watching some of it
the Brogan had the vegetarian guy on and
the other guy who's yeah Chris crecer
and the other guy yeah the game changers
thank my bunch in the argument that was
a movie game changer but it wasn't
scientific I watched it it wasn't
scientific it over Illinois you it's
like it was like they took a couple of
vegan athletes a couple out of the
massive group of athletes who and they
even the worst part was they were like
well Conor McGregor was eating two
steaks a day and Nate Diaz was a
vegetarian an atheist beat him
oh it's like I was like you guys lost me
on this one good you lost me on this and
that engines are argued like we're about
facts I don't but I would he actually
you had a lot of good every doctors know
I did the vegetarian guy games well yeah
the guys involved oh yeah it's not like
Rogan homeboy who's going against like
met you first that Syria and that that
guy was ready to go ready to go I want
to see it I want actually really good
pot yeah there's a lot of the Elias
altars a lot of the doctors on there are
are have vegetarian based clinics and
make a lot of money off it I'm not
saying they're not saying that I'm not
saying that you gotta watch me yeah you
bring that up to him and he's just get
youth so I was so ready to go
I think there's a lot of value in eating
a plant-based don't think you just all
meat all the time yeah I don't think
eating meat supplementing meat is a bad
thing though if there's just too too
many cultures throughout the world that
live a long time and are very vibrant
that have eaten meat way more than our
vegetarian I think any diets final in
moderation I think anything there you
got something doing just playing for the
answer
I don't think doing just meets the
answer my moderation is the answer
moderation is the answer be tough to go
just plants man I can't do it wish I
could I wish I had the discipline I
don't like it and I never eat a salad in
my [ __ ] life when I didn't want it to
be over I love so never had a salad in
my life
never ate cabbage or any vegetable where
I was like let me get this out of the
way to get to the meat oh I like
Brussels sprouts I don't give a [ __ ]
about yeah you know what I like Brussels
sprouts with bacon
otherwise go [ __ ] yourself and I'm not
stopping and so I get that shredded
I forgot use a UFC fighter yeah yeah
executive producers are all Swartz Nager
Wow Lewis Hamilton there's a lot of big
names it even James Cameron's attached
to it too yes Jackie Chan uh-huh yeah
but these guys come late in life as
they're older it's it's you know as I
get older red meat I drink wine and red
mean I'm and if it's not 4:00 in the app
it's hard to break down right box yeah
so as you get older it really does cheat
your end your you have less enzymes and
stuff and you you do you should probably
transfer to a plant-based diet I can
believe that or at least you have your
plants right yeah yeah I think so I had
a ton of meat in case II did but it's
not a barbecue well the meat foolish is
the problem is the sugary barbecue sauce
you don't feel like that's my fave I
also think if you cook overcooked meat
so for my four schools I had to eat a
bunch of meat I'm pretending I'm eating
Buffalo in the scene and I was but it
was I had to eat it it was real Buffalo
no but it was state but they cooked it
like through and through Oh son you
can't have it rushes it's in the thing I
left the nutrients are gone
I don't know I I can't digest that [ __ ]
out it's sat in my face like four
[ __ ] hours no bar oh I look like a
nice rib or like brisket like yeah it's
nice I love uh I'm not I don't I'm not
sure I'm going vegan I would like to try
it
I wish I had the discipline but so so so
did you so you listen to that debate and
weird no I just I got 30 I got 30
minutes into it but I don't I haven't
watched the documentary I don't know any
the facts I was impressed with how
homeboy was defending his points because
it was Rogan that other dude
kind of like picking apart the
documentary boy that dude was ready
mm-hmm
he was like bring up slide 101 what do
you say keke keke bring up slide 303
keke he was just ready yeah just a
preparation he did I admire that me too
anyway your mouth oh he's ready to go
you can if you can defend it yeah no
matter I don't need to watch it to know
you know I don't think anyone has the
right answer whatever's best for your
body but I know moderations
Mediterranean diet I mean they
the Italians always ate mostly like the
southern teens because they couldn't
afford nice right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]